what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday october 28th
we're back [__] without the herpes
listen the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com
i got boxes of 400 [__] mugs going
out
and who do you think is helping me
stamps.com and i don't have to go
nowhere
you're still going to the post office
aren't you i'll bet you're paying full
price on postage also
that's why i use stamps.com i send
letters
i ship packages i got a friend in jail i
mail them a letter every two weeks
anytime anywhere right from my [__]
computer
you could buy print and ship it's that
simple
with stamps.com you pay a whole lot less
you get discounts up to 40
from the post office rates and up to 62
off ups shipping rates my wife has been
with stamps.com since jesus left chicago
and we've been sending t-shirts out
hats mugs whatever the [__] you need now
we're sending mugs again who do you
think we're using
stamps.com you got a small business
stamps.com is a must-have so do me a
favor stop wasting time going to the
post office
go to stamps.com instead why because
there's no risk
there's no [__] risk use promo code
joey write this down
joey to j-o-e-y a special offer that
includes a four week trial
plus free postage listen to me free
postage and a digital scale
that's all with stamps.com and their no
long-term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com right now
do me a favor click on the microphone at
the top of the home page
and type in joey that stamps.com
promo code joey stamps.com
never go to the post office again summer
is here
and the time is right for dancing
in the street anyway the joint is
brought to you by blue shoe
blue chew is tremendous what does it do
it's an online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra
and cialis at a fraction of the cost
listen you papa blue chew they taste
and 30 minutes later you're ready to
rock you can take them any time day and
night
the process is very [__] simple okay
you can either go to your doctor
and him you know ask him doc i don't
know what's going on with me
i'm not my my erections aren't any good
you know how embarrassing it is to just
say those [__] words
[__] that with blue chew you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you talk to one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved which is within minutes
you'll receive the prescription within
days
the best part it's online no visits to
the doctor
no awkward conversations you don't got
to go to the [__]
pharmacy and the lady looks at you weird
look at this guy he needs viagra [__]
you
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
not even the mailman knows so do me a
favor
even if you don't need him you want to
be the best you could be right
why show up with one bullet when you can
show up with 22.
that's what i'm trying to give you i
wanted to walk home with a limp and say
what the [__] was that
this [__] broke me i'm going to
sex anonymous
that's what happens when you take blue
true you sling dick like the captain
kirk of the enterprise
so if you could benefit from the extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and they've got a
special deal for you you ready
you can try blue chew for free free
just use promo code joey pay five dollar
shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code joey to
receive
your first month free f-r-e-e
and as always i want to thank blue chew
for sponsoring the joints so go to
bluechew.com right now
and start the process it's monday
[__] let's get this party started
you got bluechu you got the fourth of
july
next week if you call bluetooth today
you'll have a package by thursday
by [__] saturday forget about it
you'll be lighting up people's [__]
with
with your dick instead of fireworks go
to bluetooth.com right now let's get
this [__] party started
welcome to uncle joy's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
we're back [__] it's monday
october 28th listen i'm very sorry about
last week
it was just too rough of a [__] week
you know my daughter was uh
she had three half days then school
ended on wednesday
i shot the tv show a day and a half i
had to go all the way to [__] queens
and all the way to [__] brooklyn
i'll never go in that [__] city again
jesus christ
there were squeegee people everywhere
people knocking on my [__] windows
the guy was telling mike the guy i went
to make a right turn i swear to god the
guy had the right to
make a right on the corner the light had
a [__] arrow
and some guy just crossed in front of
him and started giving him the finger
and [__]
listen i'm not going over there no more
not told if they [__] clear that out
or they hire a new [__] man but we're
here to talk about something that i
wanted to get off my chest with you
[__] for the last
10 months that's why last week was
[__] crucial uh
you know we had father's day last week
mike wanted to spend it with his kid
i had the [__] softball tournament
which they [__] ended up winning she
got a trophy she was happy
you know it's just a lot of things and
uh it's good to take a break once in a
while you don't want to be a slave to
your [__] job dog it's good to take a
break and
sit on the couch and fart and smell your
farts ain't nothing i'm [__] wrong
with that
you know i try to relax listen guys i
don't know how to [__] relax
and every time i chew too try to relax
something [__] happens my wife bought
a hammock
beautiful hammock mike it holds 400 500
[__] pounds
she hung it up perfectly i go let me go
relax like a regular [__] american
right because i never really
i don't understand that you ever see
people in a lounge chair and they go
like to a [__] like into a trance
i've tried going into a trance
it don't work for me so i go out to the
[__] thing i go let me just go out
there my daughter and my wife are
upstairs so i go in the backyard
it's kind of cloudy out i don't know
what to expect i just want to relax and
see
get a little wilderness so i lay in the
hammock dog
it went all the way down boom like it
just didn't even swing or nothing
so i was like what am i gonna do i'm a
fat [__] so i just i swear to god i just
crossed my arms and i'm like i'm gonna
die in there
and i just looked up at the trees for
about 15 minutes just breathing
it was beautiful then it started raining
and i'm like [__]
and i said [__] it you know because
she's not gonna hear my cries
i wouldn't even yell i was just going
terry
terry and i'm like i know she's not
gonna hear me so i just sat in the
[__]
hammock getting rained on looking at
chipmunks and [__]
and next thing you know my wife comes
out she's like joe joe and i'm like
i'm over here in the hammock she [__]
almost died of [__] laughter she goes
it's all the way to the floor
how are you even enjoying it like i
wasn't i was making believe i was in a
canoe
i took myself to a place where i was in
a canoe i was with indians
i was taking a nap we were crossing over
the bridge
it never ends in my [__] life you
know i go to relax the one day
i go to the softball listen i work out
in the mornings
and then to decompress just not to ride
the bike and stuff i go for a little
mile walk you know it's two times around
the thing
three times around the thing sometimes i
smoke a number sometimes i just go
straight and absorb the vitamin c
you're not going to believe this mike
i'm walking i'm minding my own business
i'm not on the [__] phone i'm just
walking thinking about life looking at
rocks and [__] you know what you do when
you're in the wilderness
and i look up and there's a [__] deer
running at me
and i'm not talking about he's like you
know you know how usually you just see
him and they see you and they start
bouncing [__] no
this [__] was running towards me
now there's a softball feeling it's got
a fence
and it goes all the way around and then
there's an opening in the middle
so you could cut through it divides the
two fields it's like a home run [__]
fence so i'm walking towards the [__]
fence i don't cut through the thing i
walk
all the way around all the way around
all the way around then i walk to my car
not that day
i walked once i go i'm feeling good let
me walk it again as i walk right here
i hear i hear these weeds and [__] and
all of a sudden i see this [__] deer
just running at me i didn't see horns or
anything i just saw a deer running at me
full [__] speed ahead so i look at
him and i go holy [__]
and i start backpedaling a little bit
but i got the [__] up knee
so i had to run you should have seen
uncle joey running i [__] turned
around
and i just started running for my
[__] life this d is gonna bite me or
whatever the [__] they do
next thing you know i don't hear him
running anymore i look
he jumped the fence and there was an
opening in the back fence
and i saw two little baby she had two
little babies with her she was running
them they were brand new
she was just running them and they're
trying to run to keep up next to and i
go
don't i feel like a [__] jerk off
that is
[__] crazy man so it was one of those
weeks don't worry about it i shot two
days i
i lifted i did everything i had to do i
feel a lot [__] better i went to the
doctor
we went over my [__] blood results
everything's beautiful
no diabetes the thing she was really
flipping out about was the cholesterol
i'm right on point i'm perfect and
that's the weights thank you
whoever invented weights for old [__]
people
thank you because it cut down on my
diabetes i don't even have diabetes but
i'm not even close to the area
my sugar was a little high so we're
trying to figure out what it was
i'm not eating sweets so it's probably
[__] white rice
or pasta you know ever since i moved
here i got italians i'm surrounded by
the best so i got italians over here and
they
knock on the door and give you homemade
pasta and lasagnas and [__]
zucchinis and all this [__] so uh my
weight's down everything's good so we're
ready to [__] rock and roll
what i wanted to talk to you guys today
was something that was going on
i was feeling and uh
through the therapist you know i started
talking to a therapist
she helped me i talked to my friends i
talked to jerry roach i talked to as
many people as i could i talked to jerry
rocha
because he's facing stage four right now
not stage four but he just has colon
cancer god bless him
uh we've been communicating a lot and
nobody could give you a great
advice as somebody who's staring at
death nobody gives you
good advice until they're in a position
where
they're appreciating life you know so
i've talked to a few people
and it was weird about three weeks ago
before i got this audition
for this tv show i got a you know you
usually have to go through wardrobe
and since we have covert now you're not
allowed to just go over there
like it used to be you go over there
they measure you and then you come back
the next day
and they put a suit on you and or they
try the costumes out and they take a
picture for the director
and the director picks out your [__]
suit so
as you'll see in the picture i put the
[__] she calls me up and she goes
what size suit are you and i go i have
no [__] idea
i haven't worn a suit in [__] years i
got like 10 of them but i just don't
wear them
so i went upstairs and i grabbed the one
that they gave me from back
batman the dark knight rises when i did
the mini series before
the movie came out i did uh this thing
for them and i meant i'll never forget
that it's a beautiful it's a calvin
klein [__] suit
they came out and they go do you want to
buy it and i go absolutely it was like
two days
before christmas and they go
if you want to buy it we'll sell a few
for 1200 bucks i don't want a 1200
suit what am i going to do i need a
fancy suit for charlie i ain't got no
job to wear it
so [__] they came back and they go
you know what merry christmas keep the
suit
so that suit was from god knows you know
whenever i did the dark
moon rises it's a black suit i don't
even think you know it's like wakes and
[__] when do i go to wake so
she asked me what the size of suit was
and she goes once you put it on and take
a [__] picture
and i put it on and my wife took a
picture of it like you're seeing right
now
and next thing you know i mean the suit
just didn't
[__] fit like it was three sizes too
big
the pants were falling off me even with
suspenders it wouldn't work
but it was pretty interesting you know
yeah i lost weight
you know [__] like that happened so in
the process of me figuring out what the
[__] was going on with me why i had all
this anxiety
you know i walked you know listen if i'm
gonna tell you guys to do something or
give you advice i have to follow my
own advice you know what i'm saying so
when you're stuck you know you try to
talk to some people but every once in a
while to talk to people who aren't
biased
you know who aren't biased somebody's
gonna give you
what they feel it is and after three
weeks of talking to the therapist she
goes i really been thinking about your
situation
your body rejecting the reefer you know
you not taking edibles
you not wanting to do comedy you not
wanting to do a lot of things
you know it came to the conclusion that
you don't really know in life
when you're [__] happy and unhappy
sometimes
you get caught up in such a circle that
it's so repetitive and it feels right
but it doesn't and that's what happened
when i moved here i came back here
and i'm around normal people and my body
and my mind did not know how to handle
it i did not
know how to act because for the last 23
years
i've been walking around fake people
and [__] pigs people who do anything
to get to where they need to be like
i've told you before
this phone doesn't ring anymore it
doesn't ring not because i don't pay the
bill
it doesn't ring because i'm in jersey
nobody needs me for anything now out of
sight out of mind
it doesn't hurt my feelings i knew the
animal i was dealing with
before i got into it but i didn't know
that i was so unhappy and when i found
out
you know like what was really bothered
like i wrote down my triggers i wrote
them down
listen i did the work i did the homework
that the therapist
assigned and i started writing down the
things that bothered me like what
gets under my [__] skin and i just
kept writing and writing and writing and
writing
and it was the life i was living in los
angeles and i didn't know it until i go
on instagram
and i look at all these other comics
and the desperation i had i'm not a
desperate person i've never been a
desperate person
but we all didn't know any better
you know how nice it is i don't have to
put my dates on twitter anymore
you know how nice you know how great
that is to me that i don't have to keep
putting dates on [__] twitter
that i could just be normal on [__]
twitter every time
i didn't want you to think that every
time you [__] looked at my twitter
page or my instagram page it's me
selling a date
you know i got sick of doing all that
[__] i just got really sick of it
i love stand-up comedy it made me the
person who i
am today but no correction
it didn't make me the person who i am
today it was part of what
made me the man that i am today and me
stepping away from it
and seeing it from a different
perspective from 2 000 miles away
made me realize something the other
night i was telling mike that
the joy i find listen
you can't watch tv no more i mean it's
just i
i'm to the point in my life i i watched
two things this week
and i only watched them because i needed
to watch these two movies i watched
to live and die in l.a great movie about
counterfeit money
half the lines i quote are stolen from
that john tatura
has some great lines in that movie have
you ever seen that mike living dining
lane by counterfeit money
i don't think yeah i don't think the
secret service
and the fbi were too happy with that
movie it's all about counterfeit money
and how they do it
the guy that played uh i forget what his
name is william defoe
played the [__] main guy he was great
uh the guy from
csi is in it he disappeared after that
was a michael mann movie
i think it's a michael mann movie don't
quote me on that
and then last night i watched the friday
night i watched the [__] crow
god damn i was crying i called my wife
my daughter down i go this is bruce
lee's son when he was fighting the black
dude with the dreads
the guy was throwing knives at him and
[__] when he stabs the guy the black
guy up against the [__] thing
my daughter's like i go yeah it's time
for you to go upstairs you don't need to
see this [__]
bruce lee's son's about to go off so
oh he yeah he got he cut that
[__] up nice
great movies but beside that at night i
come downstairs
i do a little reading and then about
quarter to ten
i make my [__] tea not the michael
jackson tea i've cut it down all i put
in the michael jackson t now is
two bags of kiko kikamoti kikoko tea
and i put two 25 sleepy time edibles
from abx
tremendous i sleep like a [__] baby
and let me tell you what my development
is i'm getting blitzed
on 50 milligrams i was getting so
blitzed on 50 milligrams i said [__] it
let's pop another one in there let's see
where it takes us and i
got to 75 milligrams let me tell you
something i call lydia and i and lee
goes you sound [__] up like a lee
i'm calling you because i am [__] up
on 75 percent
75 lee we haven't even [__] gotten we
used to have to take 200
just to get a giggle out of us and then
we would go up to 800 a thousand
2 000 i am getting high on 75 [__]
milligrams
and then i smoke a little little bit and
i come back here and i play the guitar
and then what i do is per mic
i put an album on and i try to play
along with the album
no bueno it's not working out for me but
you know what i'm learning different
things i'm learning like oh this is that
chord
this is that i don't know what it's
called i don't know if it's a c
or an e i don't know and i don't care
the best thing is that i'm getting
therapy for music but i made a mistake
i got really high the other night and i
put the album on
animals animals
breaks it down for you i'm sitting there
i'm sitting back and i'm taking in this
animal album
animals is about dogs pigs it classifies
people
as dogs pigs and sheep
pretty [__] close to what we're
living through right now
the dogs are the people that make things
happen the pigs are the [__]
these people that inflict greed and
[__]
this creepy feeling on t all the time
when you see him they're just capitalist
[__] pigs
that's all they are trust me and that's
what i consider agents and that whole
scene in hollywood
i became one of those [__] pigs
without even [__]
knowing and trust me i wasn't a pig like
i got a call the other day for my agent
going listen
guess what you could raise your ticket
prices to 45
people are paying 45 for tickets
i go why don't you [__] go jump off a
[__] bridge or something like that
it's the toughest time in [__]
america and you want to charge 45
for a [__] comedy i mean i don't even
want to talk to them no more they are
just
the most embarrassing people i've met in
my life but then
i got to be honest with you i looked at
some of the comics that some of them are
still my friends and i love them dearly
and you could see the desperation coming
through the [__] screen
all that stuff that's not the reason why
i got into [__] comedy
i got into comedy to drop out
to be part of a gang like the hells
angels without [__] motorcycles i
want to be a part of something
but at the end of the day i wasn't a
part of anything i was a part of a group
of guys
and a group of women that's all about
them and they're trying to advance
them i advanced me by working hard and
living in a [__] car and driving
across the country
i never expected to get to the heights
that i did in comedy i'm grateful i did
i'm happy for [__] felons that now
you have a purpose
you know that you could do it this
podcast was never about me looking down
at you
me showing you what i didn't have oh
look at me i'm grilling up steaks
tonight who gives a [__] there's people
that are eating peanut butter and jelly
[__] sandwiches
you know during the pandemic i saw
people putting lobster tails up online
and [__] people are barely [__]
eating they're scared
but this is the world we live in today
and i accept it for what it was
but ever since i moved here i had to do
something that was really rough i had to
accept my new life
i had to accept feeling normal and that
raised my anxiety
when i'm around normal people don't give
a [__] about instagram i've never been
around those people
i've never been around those people for
the last 30 for the last 23 years i've
been around people that
come into your life and they don't come
into your life like mike came into mind
they come into
your life with a [__] agenda
you know so many people were contacting
me with an agenda that i couldn't
[__] fulfill
i still got a girl now that i love to
pieces i love her to pieces
and she contacts me all the time for
advice
and i give her the advice and it's like
it's still not enough i cannot help i'm
not there
i'm not there so i can't help you you're
there you have to make these decisions
upon yourself
as a comic but the real clinker this
week what really made me realize where i
was and why i'm so happy and why i'm a
different
person now is because i had a long
overdue conversation with lee in fact we
spoke two nights in a row for about an
hour
and i called them to do one thing number
one i apologize to him
and number two we figured out what was
going on
we were enabling each other you know lee
couldn't lose a pound
i couldn't lose a pound what's lee doing
right now he's down 100 pounds
he's dating a little [__] girl he met
he's going out
he's a complete different i didn't it
took me a while
to get it like what is lee doing i mean
we talk
every other night and stuff like this
but this conversation this week was the
first time
we were candidly honest with one another
and i don't know if you guys know this
i'm sorry if i'm letting this
i think we discussed it on the podcast
on the church lee was seen a therapist
for a long time
we were seeing the therapist it's none
of my business
what he was talking to the therapist
about i would never
ask him i would break his balls and say
to them what you say to you today you
know
and he would give me little bits and
blurbs of what she would say
so i never thought about it then i
thought about the blips and blurbs
he told me this week while i was on the
phone with him
lee was miserably unhappy
miserably unhappy and i believe when did
you see the change in me and he goes i
started seeing
you not being yourself like in
and it was after the netflix special
because i hadn't worked hard all those
years
to do a netflix special that in my eyes
i didn't like because
i didn't like the whole thing i didn't
like how i was treated i didn't like
the [__] how it all went down
my agent made me get a manager to get
the [__]
thing and now a couple weeks ago i got a
bill from my agent
for a commission from a residual check
from my special i called them up and i
go you got nothing coming to you
you know why you got nothing coming to
you because you can call you know in l.a
oh he's great friends of mine well if
you go to a later game with a [__]
guy
tell him listen i need my [__] guy to
get a special
no he made me get a manager pay him 10
of my [__] money
and then that guy grouped me in with a
bunch of [__] mooks
into this thing i ended up shooting it
thank god with yamaneika and [__]
big j and [__] you know christine
ended up working i mean i had fun while
i was there with christina and yamaneka
and [__]
you know whoever else was there the nice
white girl i forget what her name was
i mean we had a great time as a crew
brad williams we had a great time as a
crew
but what was going on i didn't like i
didn't feel right i didn't feel it was
why i gotten to stand up
and that's when my descent started like
i didn't even you know i started
drinking the [__] coffees
i had to you know eat uh you know 600
milligrams a day
before the podcast just to get through
the day
i had to take two edibles at night to
get on stage i had to drink four
[__] espressos to get on stage i mean
that
these things were just it was uh
it was very [__] disturbing when i
look at it now
last week i was doing something i went
outside to check the car to see my
neighbor and i come back and there's
this big box in front of the house
that was the [__] turning point i saw
this big box in front of my house
and i brought it in i'm like i wonder
what's in this [__] box
three of the prettiest [__] bongs
you've ever seen in your life beautiful
beautiful little one a medium one and
we'll be using them
but when i looked at it i got
i closed the box and i put the box in
the garage
when i left la i had two or three
beautiful bongs i gave this
a thousand dollar bong i gave it to a
friend of mine because i wasn't gonna
leave that there
but the little uh the little mule and
the big mule
i left under the sink at the old house
and i didn't look back i don't care if
the landlord found it
i don't care if the clean lady found it
i left him there
and without knowing i did a bunch of
stuff without knowing like i left the
bongs there
without knowing what it signified i left
the [__]
uh you know i i went to the comedy store
and i really really said goodbye i put
my hand on the wall and i said goodbye
i was saying without consciously knowing
i was saying goodbye to that whole
[__] world
i was just saying goodbye listen i smoke
pot now
i'm not a pothead anymore that's a big
[__] difference i was telling mike
i'm smoking this weed at night this
cactus buds
from [__] the ice cream shop if you
get a minute
go get some cactus buds or the regular
cactus og it's like 35
or 36 percent whoo because i thought i
was going to come back
smoking lower end reefer but i can't
find no lower end reefer
so i smoked the cbd weed for a couple
weeks just to really bring down
remember that joint i smoke i started
taking two or three hits from it
to calm me down it really worked cleaned
up my lungs a little bit you know
and now i mean that
60 days or whatever i did where
i didn't smoke for 30 something days and
then i just started taking one hit
one hit because that's all you're
supposed to do with this weed you're not
to be smoking blunts that is [__]
you're just wasting [__] weed no
wonder i was going through an eighth in
[__] two days i got friends that tell
me an eighth lasting a [__] week i
was going through an eighth
in a day and a half i would buy 4 8 and
i'd be back at the store two days later
just smoking at the office smoking at my
house you know whatever smoking outside
bringing joints to the comedy store and
that's great listen i had a lot of
[__] fun
but once i moved here all that [__] went
away how did it go away did i try to
what do you think i went to name meeting
and say hi my name is joey
i'm a potsmart remember that idiot that
went to [__] celebrity rehab for
smoking pot
if you go to a rehab for smoking pot go
shoot yourself you know what i'm saying
what the [__] is wrong with you you know
i had a friend who went to a rehab for
smoking cigarettes
that i kind he went to like two rehabs
for smoking cigarettes his parents put
him in a rehab
for smoking cigarettes i saw him one day
he's like i gotta smoke a cigarette
[__] under the car
because they got cameras all over me i
can't smoke [__] cigarettes
you know listen you got a problem with
[__] pills or coke or heroin that's
one thing
weed you could do on your own there's
really no [__] withdrawals you get
you get [__] listen i had some
[__] weird dreams i had
one that had a dream my mother was on
the bed with me talking to me
i walked right the [__] up i came down i
threw holy water on myself it was
[__] scary
i got a little holy water from the
church i go to on sundays a little
bottle
just in case the devil shows up i swear
to god i threw holy water on myself and
said a [__] prayer
i had a dream about my father i had a
dream about anna bender
i mean my [__] dreams were getting
too [__] vivid i was like
[__] this [__] it was like alpha brain
dreams i love doing alpha brain
but those six weeks that cycle i put
myself on
those are [__] clear dreams i mean
you see your dick going into her
ass you see the toilet hair she left on
her at the toilet paper
i mean i'm not that i have sexual dreams
but i'm just saying to you
that's how clear your [__] dreams are
on alpha brain
so you know my dreams are just it was
three weeks of [__] waking up going
i didn't remember that [__] [__] with
my mother you know
but in my conversations with lee i mean
both nights we both got off the phone
really [__] happy
because we both got to tell each other
the truth you know
i had to stop the podcast it had to end
it wasn't going to continue i couldn't
continue that
it was great on film what you guys were
seeing was funny and blah blah blah blah
blah but
he even said there was kind of like a
[__] thing in the room
you know and i remember nobody had ever
came to that spot like that
wasn't invited
and one night i told lee lee and in the
podcast
august 10th whatever it must have been
two hours after that that him and him
and i were
wrapping up and somebody drove by some
girls and a guy and they were like joey
lee come out and we're like what the
[__]
it's time to get out of here like
everything
was pointing at that direction you know
lee was making good money you know we
were doing good things together
but we weren't happy we just weren't
happy you think lee just mysteriously
lost
a hundred pounds he was just carrying
that was the only way he was suppressing
what he was feeling he was in pain
you know from what i'm getting from this
therapist
i was in pain at first i was like i
think this lady's crazy but then i
started looking
and i started looking at the lives that
comics have to live
and the way these agents i remember
being over here shooting the [__]
soprano movie
and these agents kept calling me so what
do you want to do about this date
what do you want to do about this date i
don't want to do nothing
i just want to shoot the soprano movie
that's what's in front of me
that's what's in [__] front of me let
me tell you something for you young
comics
i'm going to give you the best advice in
the world and i'm thinking of writing a
book on the [__] subject
stay an open micro as
much as you can wear that label
and wear it proudly wear that open mic
label proudly go out
have a great time drink
do drugs get your dick sucked
that's what it means to be an open miker
to get into comedy get your click
together get your four or five guys that
you live and breathe for like i had in
seattle
with josh wolfe and brody and tana manu
and you know we just had our own little
[__] click that's
comedy that's real comedy that's comedy
from the heart
you're making fifty dollars you barely
pay your rent
as as un as miserable as that lifestyle
sounds
it's so much fun i had a great time in
seattle as an open micro
slash beginning to feature act and let
me tell you something i had a great time
when i got to the store i mean knock on
wood she passed me
i had a great time it was where i belong
i was having a great time there they pay
a spot guy but it's a college you're
learning i'm following paul mooney
i'm talking to rogan i met dice i mean
all this was great
you know all those early movies i had a
great time getting them nobody wanted to
talk to me as a stand-up [__] you
i'm you're not going to stop me you know
just because you don't like my stand up
i'm too dirty i do this with my hand
oh we can't put him in montreal [__] you
i never wanted to be a part of that i
didn't know it
i remember bobby slate inviting me to
montreal he said i'll sneak into the
dirty show
and i took a flight to detroit
and i was going to connect from detroit
i was going to sneak into canada try
there was a comic that had a show in
canada he said he'd get me in and then i
could get the montreal on my own
and i'll never forget waking up and
going i'm not going to montreal i wasn't
invited
i'm going to go up there like a
desperado and go on stage and try to do
what
what am i going to get from going up
there this what am i missing
if they don't want me there i don't
[__] belong there
and i'll never forget like calling the
airline and going listen i'm not going
to [__] whoever my friend
and going forget it but i'm not going
why i said i'm not [__] going
and i remember that there was a comedy
club down the corner it was an
african-american comedy club named
coco's comedy club and i walked in there
and i said listen i'm here for a couple
days do you mind if i pop in
she was cool as [__] she let me pop in i
got to meet some brothers
it was a great three days it was a lot
better than me going to montreal because
i didn't belong there
and then when i went to l.a listen what
you people forget was in 2009 after i
got married i was done
i was done i had seen it for what it was
i moved into the valley
i had friends that were gonna put me in
their tv shows i got a call from greg
garcia last week
i'm going to pittsburgh in september to
shoot three episodes of a show with
christina p
is in it his new show for amazon you
know i have friends that that are
writers
and i'll just [__] take their spoons
whenever they call me up and go you want
to play a [__]
rapist i'm in what do i give a [__] it's
three days and i get insurance and i eat
and i see some people and
that's all i want to [__] do but no
the podcast revolution came in
i got into it and yes it was very
interesting at first
it was very funny but i think by me
putting my heart on the line and telling
you everything about me
then all of a sudden 10 years later
started people started taking that and
using it against me
in emails and in videos you got these
guys now that
have shows based on what people say and
they analyze you
and meanwhile they don't even have a
[__] talent they can't even play the
[__] flute they can't even play a
[__] cowbell
and they're they're judging you so i
don't know what the [__]
has happened to comedy what the [__]
but one conclusion came out of this week
i don't want to be involved in that no
more i'm gonna put up regular [__]
tweets now
i can put up lick my balls now sniff my
[__]
i don't have to worry about [__]
dates am i saying i'm not gonna do
comedy again
no i'm not saying that i'm not doing
comedy that style no more
i'm not doing comedy that style anymore
i'm trying to figure out what to do
with my life and the agents i'm acting
we're doing a podcast on tuesday we
signed the contract for the [__] book
we're up to chapter nine
we got till march of 2022
to hand it in because there's so much
[__] material we're doing an audio
book
so i have so many other things going on
plus the main thing
i'm a father to a little girl this week
i had to do something that i thought i'd
never have to do
wednesday i don't know what was going on
upstairs all i know is
i went upstairs and my wife was crying
on the bed
and i go what happened and she just went
off
on you know that she cleans cat [__]
and all this other [__] and nobody helps
her and you know i i try to help her as
much as i can
but i think mercy puts it over the top
they had some type of conversation and
mercy said something to her i don't know
what happened
all i know is that my wife said i gotta
leave and she got in the car
and left for a half hour i went in there
and i talked to mercy
i didn't yell i just asked her what
happened and i go listen you can't
have these beefs or mom i go now there
was a party on wednesday a kid's party
that she wanted to go to we punished her
and we i made up four pages
well i will not argue with mom anymore i
will not argue with mom so when she came
home on the last day of school
she had to clean her bathroom clean her
bedroom
vacuum it and i'll never forget i had to
go upstairs and bring her the four
sheets
and put him down guys it was the most
painful thing i ever did in my life
i had to leave she took a punishment
she sat down she wrote i think on page
three her mother said she had a little
nervous breakdown
because she thought that once she
finished she could go to the party and
the mother told her no
you're grounded for the [__] day
let me tell you something that old
cliche line this is gonna hurt you
this is gonna hurt me more than hurts
you
it hurt me i had to leave i never
thought i'd have to punish her for the
day
you know i had to leave but guess what
when i got home
i went in the room i told her you're
done
it's over and the most important thing
is we will never
ever bring this up again and this is
what life should be like
you know what 30 years ago i did time
i didn't have to tell you [__]
i'd have to tell you
i told you for a reason because i wanted
you to know
the animal you were dealing with i
didn't want to hide nothing from you i
don't want you to come back
in 10 years ago you never told me you
went to prison for kidnapping i don't
really like you anymore i don't like
doing business with criminals no
my purpose wasn't that my purpose was to
let you know that yes
i [__] up but i paid my dues
and i became a [__] functioning
member of society
that's what this podcast is about not
for me to grill steaks and [__] show
you the steaks i'm grilling
or who i'm hanging out with or whose ass
i'm kissing that week
if you notice i don't kiss nobody's
[__] ass i don't even kiss my own
[__] ass i don't give a [__]
so all that lifestyle is [__] behind
me and that's what i was going through
that's what all the anxiety was eating
away at me
was that [__]
i'm back in the normal place a and b
i don't have to ever deal with that [__]
anymore i'm not going to austin i'll
probably go down in september
to promote the sopranos if if they let
me if not that's fine too
joe's still my brother i don't care what
you know i don't care about spotify or
anything
listen let me do ads for a show
they let our podcast go up on spotify i
guess i got music on there or whatever
i got no beasts on anybody i don't want
to create no problems for anybody
if joe says come on down in september
with david chase or whatever
i'm down now get to see bert you know i
don't know if i'll be performing yet
but for right now man i just i'm gonna
enjoy the summer
i'm gonna be a [__] father
and it's rough it really is rough i had
a
i had a war within myself on this side i
had the palestinians
and on this side i had the jews and they
were just throwing rocks at each other
in my [__] brain
i was confused all day so i had to make
a [__] statement
and i remember i was at the gym one
morning lifting and i finished and jimmy
florentine was in there and he was
waiting for me
and i looked him right in the aisle i
came to a conclusion
i'm not doing [__] comedy right now
i'm gonna do it when i'm [__] good
and ready
i'm not letting anybody pressure me i'm
going to guns and roses on the 11th of
september
uh some people want me to do a show up
north in northberg and you know what i
love them
i respect northberg and i love
everything they stand for it was my home
they tolerated me but in my life i got
to keep mormons distance right now
you know a lot of things happening in my
life
that are [__] changing you know for
example let me tell you this
the people i thought were going to be my
friends when i got here
are not my friends i got a whole new
batch
of [__] friends and the people that
have reached out to me the most
are my friends from grammar school in
fact we're planning a little [__]
very quiet reunion amongst us
i want to read you a text message that i
got from one of them
last week and this is what really got me
thinking about
why these people are reaching out to me
and now these are the people that knew
me when i wasn't a thief
when i wasn't a piece of [__] and when i
wasn't on drugs i smoked pot with these
guys
on fridays and we giggled and we put
vizin in our eyes and put [__]
you know chateau number five some shitty
cologne or aqua velva on
so your mother wouldn't smell it but i
want to read you this
email that this kid sent me and it
really made me think
about life and what i did
hey brother man i'm on my way to the
valley hospital
there's a mast in my chest just in case
this is
it i just wanted to tell you that i love
you
and i couldn't have asked for a better
childhood friend
how lucky was i
that text
meant more to me than any tv show
any movie any film any netflix special
you could rub your [__] ass with that
[__]
that [__] text message changed me
right there
i immediately i don't know where valley
hospital i call my sister who's a nurse
practitioner and i asked her where it
was she found out for me she told me
they wouldn't give me information on the
phone the reason why he's not answering
the phone
is because maybe he didn't have a
charger in the hospital
i almost didn't sleep all night i
reached out to his sister on facebook
his name is dean dean was with me
in the sixth grade one day and we were
going to get a wiffle ball bat
our story to our parents were we were
getting wiffle ball
bats we were cut off the bottom of the
bat where you gripped the bat
and we were fill it up with rocks and
then we would crazy glue
the handle back on and tape it and we
would use it as a bat and wiffle ball
but also as weapons against the [__]
kids
so when people would hit us with those
[__] durotesque
uh tubes we would whack them with a
woofer you ever get hit with a wiffle
ball back with rocks in it
it's not a pretty [__] day for you so
me and dean
and my mother's bar you know this is how
back i go with these guys
so i'm with dean and my mother's bar my
mother's at a track
and it's me and the fat guy bernardo do
campo
arnado was the guy that would simulate
masturbation in front of us he would
[__]
he would go look at you [__]
[__] playing [__]
uh wiffle ball you should be at home
getting your dick sucked and went like
in the sixth grade me and dean
you know in the 70s it's not like now
like one night i took my daughter
to dinner with my wife and we stopped at
the comedy store and they actually came
over to me they go you know after eight
o'clock
your daughter can't be here and i was
like that's fine i wasn't mad or angry i
understood
you know liquor law licenses and [__]
but in the 70s a kid could sit at a
[__] bar till three in the morning
they wouldn't say [__]
and i'd invite all my friends when your
mother has a bar
and you're a [__] kid and you invite
all your friends to your mother's bar
to watch a tv show and they're all
drinking cokes with cherries in them
make them believe we're [__] you know
burp backpack
we're all sitting there making we didn't
even smoke or nothing but we were
like we were actually sitting there like
we thought we were a rat pack
with little [__] uh rock glasses with
rocks in it and coca-cola and cherries
and you know we just sit there all of us
and drink and [__] like it was great
to be at a bar when you're [__] in
the sixth grade
with like 10 6th graders drinking cokes
or cherries in them playing unlimited
pool
it was fantastic my mother would cook
cuban food for us
but on this particular day she wasn't
there we went to hernandez we got a
cuban sandwich dean is an irish dude
lapreet and he loved all that cuban [__]
but he was
you know in those days it was the 70s
white kids were scared to go with the
spanish joints it wasn't like it is now
that you go in there let me get
high i want two empanadas you know in
the [__] 70s
you were white you ate pizza and
sandwiches you didn't really [__] with
the cubans
and the cubans didn't [__] with you you
know but
these kids would come up and you know
dean lapre listen
we're gonna have this reunion it's me
dean
david ruiz chucky mcbreen from ramapo
college who i got
the covet shot for the jay and jay
kovitz shot for
after 40 years of friendship i called
him up and i go i know you
we were talking and he goes when he gets
his he wants a j and j
shot he doesn't know where to get it who
hooked us up our another childhood
friend
lucio fernandez who's a commissioner in
union city
told us come up and get the [__] j j
shot not even north bergen it was
[__] union city
so we got lucio we got chucky mcbree
from ramapo we got dean lapree coming
my sister lisa we got louis hernandez
who i used to call something else
because he was the i didn't call him
that but he was dominican and had an
afro
they called them louis black lives
matter so
we can't say what they used to call them
he's a psychiatrist he's showing up
and these are the people i have been
talking to lately
all the people from high school what i
did i tell you that i used to do drugs
with
and go crazy with their persona
they're still doing their own thing
there's six of them that stopped talking
to me
and that's fine i could give the
frenchman's [__]
it was time to move on anyway this is a
whole new [__] life
with a whole new [__] set of rules
you know
i don't know if i finished this tv show
yet uh they told me they'd see me again
maybe after this week i mean we're going
into the fourth of july we don't expect
dick to happen
after wednesday we're putting up a
podcast wednesday but after wednesday
everybody's gonna be thinking about
potato salad and you know
uh what color the picnic tables are and
do we have enough fireworks
ain't much gonna happen i'll still be on
patreon dropping [__] knowledge for
you guys
so you're not bored to [__] pieces
but what i wanted you to take out of
this podcast the most important thing
was what my wife told me you know
there's a little boy that comes to the
softball games
great kid i love him to death there's a
little couple kids that you know
the girls have little brothers and stuff
but there's one boy his father's [__]
great his
mother's great the little girl is great
her in mercy went to the movies
mercy really loves her to death but the
little brother is um
he's on the spectrum you know and that's
not his fault he's still a great kid
at the games he sits on my laps and he
[__] pulls my ear him and
another kid named joey they love
tormenting me and [__]
and i love him both but
my wife said that he usually ask his
mom like mom what's going on with me
mommy can you fix me you know
it's it's and he's a good kid you know
and i play with him and i throw the ball
for him and i do magician trips can i
take my finger off and all that [__] you
know what i'm saying like i
i do all that [__] with them and uh
i'll put a picture up for you guys and
me and joey joey's another one that
always tortures me punches me
[__] i always tell him because he's
italian
but i always go mira paharito and then i
tickle him and he's like ah so he tries
to tickle me at the restaurant and [__]
it's great
but you know he always tells his mom
mommy can mommy what's going on with me
can you fix me you know
and a couple nights ago i looked at my
wife and i you know i feel like that
little boy
maybe last thursday i i told my wife
you know i feel like that little boy at
times like oh you know i told my wife
mommy can you [__] fix my head i
don't know what's going on
with me anymore she goes what's
happening
thank god i got tighter with my wife
during this pandemic
thank god i had the power to
be free with a one of the biggest things
yeah i had the movie this week and mercy
was graduating
and mike had father's day and mike's son
had ear surgery and we had a lot of
things going on
but i can't lie to you guys sunday night
was the worst
panic attack i've ever gotten in my life
since august 21st
i mean i basically had to get out of the
car my bro
thank god my brother george was here i
love him with all my heart
50 years he's been there for me he was
waiting for me
with carol on the balcony and i walked
up the balcony
and i basically took my shirt off in
public which i never do
you know i haven't pulled the bert
crusher in years and i
got the knees the bag of ice that fanny
sent me from my knee surgery
and i just had to put it on my neck
that's how bad the panic was
and i take my shoes off i was sweating
perfusiously my palms
and uh you know i took my medication
i popped a little [__] football and i
just sat downstairs with my brother and
talked
and at the end of the night you know my
wife came down we put mercy to sleep
blah blah blah
and uh
i asked my wife you know i told my wife
what was going on from a to z
from you know she's noticed that there's
no wreath of smoke downstairs or outside
you know there was a little box i used
to put my roaches in the box disappeared
and i told my wife you know i don't know
what's going on
i spoke to the therapist i've spoken to
jerry roach and jerry roach really
helped me i've spoken to mike i've
spoken to lee
i've come to terms with all this [__]
but there's still a piece missing and my
wife looked me in the eye and she goes
joey
you're not the same person you were in
l.a number one and number two
the suit just doesn't fit anymore
the suit outgrown you you're not that
person you moved on
and there's nothing wrong with that it's
something that i had to accept
you know i was walking around here
having no i
you know i was having a hard time i was
quit there's an expression people use
that that creeping in their skin they
don't feel comfortable in their skin for
the last
two months i haven't felt comfortable in
my [__] skin you know and uh
i do now because now i understand that
i'm not the i'm not that person
that's not who i wanted to be and that's
who i ended up being
half those people i was hanging out with
them la
i don't even think i could talk to them
no more with different people
with different people this pandemic
changed us you know we all changed
every seven years in 2007 i i stopped
doing cocaine
in 2014 i be i became a [__] father
and i didn't know what i was walking
into
you know all i wanted all i knew in my
heart it was
that i wanted it to work and in 2021
i realized you know
four months before my 30th anniversary
of comedy
that i didn't want to do comedy anymore
i didn't want to
be involved with those [__] grandma
killers those people who kept their
clubs open
and put them in full [__] capacity
and
and still thought that people needed to
do [__] comedy
and you know they covered up covet
things they did a lot of bad things a
lot of people
i can't see myself doing business with
them i don't want to do business with
them
ever again you know how can you do that
to people people were [__] getting
sick
even though you got a ppl loan and
you're [__] still keeping the club
open
listen i respect the clubs that opened
up and
spaced people and wore gloves and you
know told people they couldn't come in
and you know
they tried they tried i don't expect you
but i never expected you to be a [__]
pig
as a club owner or a pig as a [__]
agent or a pig as a human being
and that's what i was surrounded with
for you people just to clarify it
i'm not a pig and i'm not a sheep i'm a
[__] dog
okay i call my own shots i follow my own
lead
i don't give a [__] what you want to do
with your life i know what i'm doing
with my life
i'm not going anywhere to prove time i'm
not in anybody's ass
i don't have to go on tour and anybody
to prove to anybody how cool i am
that shit's done with i'm a bad
[__] i took myself out of the
[__] rocket ship
and i made it all the way to a [__]
house and i did it with
ball's heart and the love of a [__]
woman you know i couldn't have done it
by myself you want me to die i did by
myself
and i did it with the love that was
surrounding from my friends
some of the friends that are still my
friends and some of them that have moved
on
you know that [__] softball field
last weekend 8 30 in the morning mercy's
godfather showed up with
his daughter you know the 11 o'clock
game on saturday [__]
my brother bobby showed up with my
cousin dennis de lorenzo [__]
tremendous the size of a [__] wall
and we were cursing at the hump and [__]
you know just we weren't saying bad
things to him
we were just saying oh good job we're
watching you [__] you know like
just to let them know
you know i had a great time i was just
living a normal life usually
i'd be in a hotel [__] kitchen eating
at 11 o'clock in the [__] morning you
know waiting there all day to go on
stage at 8 o'clock at night
like i said i'm not saying never again
i'm never saying that
what i'm trying to tell you is for right
now i'm a happier person
i'm enthusiastic i have different things
going on
and i hope you accept me for what the
[__] i am when it comes to do comedy
you'll find me at [__] uh uncle
vinnie's i'll be ready to go
tip top magoo from time to time i write
a joke in a notebook now
but nothing serious i'm just trying to
work on the book
and i'm just trying to get my life
together then again i want to
apologize to lee for
you know enabling him and like i said we
enabled each other
but at the end of the day we really
really loved each other and
we love each other even more now because
we had this talk we got it out in the
open of what was really really eating
him
and what was eating me for the whole two
weeks i kept asking my wife i wonder
what's eating gilbert grape
it was all that [__] it's that i'm not a
[__] pig
i'm not i did my time
it's over i don't give a [__] about what
publishers sign this
what they think about a video all that
shit's over with i don't give a [__]
you know they're gunning for rogan now
the times is doing calling a bunch of
people the business reporter
is calling a bunch of people who gives a
[__]
you can't cancel what you can't [__]
cancel you can't cancel me
i don't give a [__] about none of that
[__] i got a couple [__] years left
of doing this and i'm gonna do it to the
best potential
if you get insulted go [__] yourself if
you want to write up about it
go [__] yourself it don't matter this
train ain't [__] stopping so if your
feelings get hurt
or you don't like what you're hearing
here i don't know what to tell you
but i have to be myself i have to be who
the [__] i am
i know my past and i know my
[__] future and i suggest
you do the same that i look at prison
and i look at the covert pandemic i'm
very sorry to a lot of people who lost
friends and family
i lost a couple myself but for
i think for 60 percent of the people
this covet
was a silver lining because they got to
see
what they really wanted to do and what
they would
didn't want to do anymore you know
people are changing jobs by the [__]
day
people got a chance to think and people
got to appreciate
what they had and i hope you were one of
those people by listening to the podcast
and see what we're doing here
everybody's changing and we're changing
for the better somebody said it on
patreon to me the other day
we're changing for the better and that's
the monday morning podcast
with uncle joey better known as the
[__] joint
okay nfts should be out this week on
patreon
if you notice we change the tiers to 5
and 15 uh september 25th
i'm thinking of renting a movie theater
out in new jersey very low area very
quiet area michael b
there gonna invite lee and we're all
gonna
[__] go to a movie together i'm gonna
try to rent the movie theater out
on matinee and all the 15
tier you know if you live close if you
can make it
uh i'll put your names on the list
there'll be no guests because we we just
got enough for us
so it's just us so don't bring a guest
and uh we'll put your name on a list i'm
gonna do this right get security
and we'll go see a movie together what's
better than that
all of us together to see the many
saints and then afterward we'll take a
[__]
one big group patreon picture and we'll
go our own ways what do you think about
that and i'm thinking of doing it all
the time
with different [__] movies i'm in the
mood to start going to see movies again
so mike what do you think
i'm down you know whether we smoke
refront if we smoke a lot of reef and
then we're going to get thrown out
then they're not going to have us back
so i suggest you get high in your car
drop your edibles in the car you never
know we might have an edible person
there
i'm not i'm not saying nothing
but every once in a while there might be
one on your seat
when you sit down at the movie theater
we might pull an ari and play [__] uh
have you there an hour earlier
looking for edibles in the mall you know
what i'm saying because
the movie theater i have in mind is in a
mall
so uh i really want to do this for you
guys i
i as i was shooting the many saints in
newark i was thinking about one thing
how
once i do this i'm done once i do this
this is why i got into comedy you know i
left here a [__] bum
i'm still a half a bum but
i'm doing this movie for new jersey i
hope that
by me being in this movie it makes you
forget the bad things i did
it proves to you that i came a long way
i left here in 85
a piece of [__] miserable lost kid who
had done
some really [__] bad things i
robbed a lot of people i i did drugs i
was
careless and i came back a responsible
man with a family what could be better
than that
i think some of that was giving me
anxiety also you know so
thank you thank you for having my back
the nft should be out this week
uh hopefully you know i talked to the
guy the other day they're excited
it's the picture of me when i'm a kid
i'm like nine whatever the [__] it is
you know kryptos down hey what are you
gonna do elvis is dead and i don't feel
so good myself
but uh for you people are just regular
people i love you guys
and thank you i'm very sorry about the
inconvenience last week
i know you guys got us on speed dial
every monday at 7 00 a.m and it'll
continue from now on
but in a couple weeks we'll take another
day week off because you know what
sometimes going away makes you [__]
strong on the way back so
i felt great today uh
i feel good about the future i feel good
about everything and i'm happy that you
guys stuck it out with me through my
[__] anxiety
and my [__] and what was going on
with me but guess what [__]
i'm back so get ready to rock we're
gonna start having a good time
on all levels thank you very much for
watching the joint
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys for
taking the ferocious here beating listen
the suit don't fit so don't expect much
anymore it's just uh
i just want to be a [__] dad and i'm
happy you guys understand that
but before we leave i got to talk to you
about a few people
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen blue chews fantastic i'm 58 years
old
i'm proud i do deadlifts and squats i
still got a semi three quarter heart on
but if i want to show up with the goods
i got to take a blue chew and listen at
first i was scared you know turn you
know turn me on to
brad williams is the one that said you
could do blue chew it's good for your
heart it started as a heart medication
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis at a fraction of
the cost
you could take it any time day or night
and it's simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com and you
talk to one of the licensed
medical providers once you're approved
you'll receive the prescription within
days
days and the best part is it's all
online
nobody knows nothing no visits to the
doctor's office
no awkward conversations no brow beating
from the lady at the pharmacy
your wife don't have to know because
your girlfriend don't have to know
can you imagine you show up with your
girlfriends you eat like 40s [__]
blue tubes
and you give a dick for like four hours
her hair's all [__] up and [__]
how are you gonna look you're gonna be
the man of the [__] year and the easy
thing is it ships right to your door
in the discreet package not even the
[__] mailman knows
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
prepared and shipped
directly usa usa this is a usa type hot
on
it's way cheaper than the pharmacy also
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
i mean even if you got a great heart on
you're 26 but you want your [__] dick
to be purple
with that pink [__] helmet vibrating
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal for you
try blue chew gratis free niente
nothing use promo code joey just pay
five dollar shipping
that's bluechu.com promo code joey
to receive your first month free and as
always
i want to thank bluechu for sponsoring
the joint
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my all-time favorites
i'm staring at 418
boxes in my garage how do you think i'm
gonna get them out of the magic carpet
[__] no stamps.com they're tremendous my
wife has been working with stamps.com
since [__] the sopranos got off the
air in 2007.
are you still going to the post office
why i'll bet you're paying full price on
posters too
that ends today that's why i use
stamps.com
my wife sends letters ship packages
t-shirts mugs hats patches anytime
anywhere right from your [__]
computer
buy print and ship it's that simple with
stamps.com you pay a whole lot less
and you get discounts up to 40 percent
off from the post office rates
and up to 62 percent from ups rates
stance.com saves businesses thousands of
dollars and hours
that's the most important your time
listen we all got one foot in the grave
with a banana peel
you want to be [__] around with boxes
all day and sending letters to the post
office
you got to wait on [__] line some
guy's breathing on you those days are
done
stamps.com saves businesses and
time which is [__] what i love like i
said to you my wife's been with them for
years
they're phenomenal you weigh you print
up the [__] stickers and the next
thing you know
they got the [__] package that's not
easy i don't know what to tell you
this works for big businesses small
businesses
stamps.com is a must-have
print us postage for any letter any
package any class of mail
it's no wonder over a million small
businesses
have already used stamps.com you could
ship
anywhere in the world straight from your
laptop schedule a pickup and the mailman
comes
to you [__] you can also take a
walk and drop it off yourself if you
like
but if not stamps.com if you're not
with stamps.com you're just [__]
slipping if you have a small business or
a big business
so stop wasting time right now by going
to the post office go to stamps.com
instead
and what i'm going to do for you on a
beautiful monday morning
use promo code joey you got a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and the digital scale
with stamps.com there's no long-term
commitment to contracts
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
on the top of the home page
and type in joey j-o-e-y
that stamps.com promo code joey you'll
be [__] tweeting me and thanking me
later with your small business
or your large business stamps.com never
go to the post office again
i want to thank bluechu i want to thank
stamps.com but most importantly i want
to thank you guys
for having our back and supporting us in
every [__] uh
possible way you can again i'm sorry
about last week
but everybody needs to take a break from
time to time stay black
have a good day and enjoy your monday
[__] we'll be back thursday
talking about [__] gambling with one
of the best in the business i love you
[__] stay black
if we don't see each other have a happy
fourth
foreign
you